- But, you recently posted
a vintage video of you,
though, from public school
and I wanted to take a
look at this with y'all.
Go ahead.
(dance music)
- [Mario] What is it? Oh, no!
(Kelly laughing)
- [Mario] Oh my God!
- [Kelly] Look at those hips!
- [Mario] Oh, oh! Oh my gosh.
(crowd cheering)
- That is so embarrassing!
You know, oh my God.
- This is my favorite one.
- Yes, yes.
Now, my buddy sent that
to me, who's in that,
my buddy Eddie Amos, we great up together.
That was either, we
couldn't figure it out,
it was either like 7th, 8th, or 9th grade.
We were in middle school.
We thought we were fly back in the day.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- [Mario] But that was a
talent show we ended up doing,
but that was funny.
- [Kelly] Do you remember
any of those moves?
You can't do any of those moves?
- [Mario] Oh my gosh, I'd do 'em for you.
- A little of this.
- I remember, well from
what I saw right there,
I remember from what I saw right there
I went, I did the ripple.
(crowd cheering)
(dance music)
- I'll do it!
- (crowd cheering)
- And then I did, no, wait, wait, hold it.
And then I think I did,
and then, and then I did.
Something like that!
(crowd cheering)
And that's it.
- Oh my God! I love a good dance break!
- See, now I'm remembering it!
Now I'm remembering it.
- Oh, the kid at play, yeah.
- Yeah, the kid at,
yeah, now I remember it.